today on the matt walsh show trump
supporters are ruthlessly attacked while
peacefully rallying over the weekend
once again
the left brings violence and mayhem with
them everywhere they go the dividing
line between good and evil in our
culture
couldn't possibly be clearer than it is
right now also five headlines including
dr fauci's declaration that masks and
social distancing
may still be necessary even after a
vaccine plus
our daily cancellation and much more all
of that on the way but first
a word from our friends over at lifelock
you know it's really important we all
spend so much time
uh online some of us spend way too much
time online or at least
my wife tells me about that about myself
but that's why when you're online you've
got to protect your online data cyber
criminals
often hide malware and emails these
deceptive emails can look like real
invoices invites
payment information with a document
attached and they're getting very
creative with this
um and and very convincing some of these
some of these scam emails can
even if you're a savvy you know internet
user um
you could still be fooled by some of
this stuff and this is why you got to
really
pay attention and protect yourself the
attachments can contain text and images
that look legitimate but when clicked on
a pop-up can appear prompting you to
click enable content or enable editing
but if you do this the attachment will
install malware on your computer and you
don't want that
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives this holiday season
you know you could miss certain identity
threats if you're just monitoring your
credit
or your bank statements those are the
kind of things we can all do on our own
but lifelock can do a lot more than that
and that's why you need lifelock
to lead and help in identity theft
protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale
on the dark web if they detect your
information has been used
in the network uh they'll send you an
alert and they'll help you get
everything straightened out
you've got to just make sure if you're
online that you're protecting yourself
it's very easy
these scumbags online of steel
identities they're very good at it so
you got to make sure to protect yourself
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions
at all businesses but lifelock can help
you feel warm and protected
this holiday season which is what we all
want so save up to 25
off your first year at lifeblock.com
walsh that's
lifelock.com walsh for 25
off well over the weekend thousands of
trump supporters rallied in washington
dc they were there in the city for much
of the day
thousands upon thousands of right
wingers trump supporters
the dreaded proud boys were in
attendance as well i'm sure there were
even some q anon proponents on the scene
i'm assuming
the point is all of the great villains
of society according to the media all of
the most brutal and extreme people
according to the media the people who
are
somehow responsible for the violence and
rioting that happens at left-wing
protests
according to the media and yet all day
these groups marched rallied
conveyed their message and there was no
violence no anarchy no crime nothing was
burned
no businesses looted imagine that but
here's the where the coincidence gets
really crazy
the violence started as soon as blm and
antifa showed up
it's almost like the left brings
violence with it everywhere it goes
sorry not almost like that that is the
case
rioting looting chaos political violence
this is all
nearly 100 of the time a tool of the
left
exclusively now you aren't going to see
uh some of this footage in the mass
media
if that's where you get most of your
news uh so let's play some of it here
i can't play it all so it's really a
matter of choosing which documented
instances of
evil leftist insanity we're going to
focus on right now
uh we'll start with this here we have
blm and antifa
harassing a group of trump supporters
who were eating dinner
after the rally and you'll see them
chucking random projectiles at the
diners
and then they move on to fireworks let's
see what that looks like
now it seems to me that throwing
fireworks is attempted murder
now you could kill someone doing that or
at least seriously main them maim them
if we have law and order in this country
i mean actual law and order instead of
just
shows called law and order and tweets
that say law and order in all caps
uh the people who did that would have
been hauled away in cuffs and would
right now be facing
20 years in prison that's the kind of
thing if you do it
your life should be ruined we need
life-ruining consequences for people who
assault and attack innocent bystanders
people who engage in political violence
otherwise known as terrorism but instead
these low-life dirt bags are allowed to
go home after their terrorism spree play
some video games
eat the lunchables their moms stocked in
the fridge sleep in
go out the next night do it all again
the difference between
revolutionaries of the past and these
so-called revolutionaries is that the
latter first of all
have no real cause except their own
empty nihilism and
hatred of everything that's good and
true in the world and second
there are no stakes for them they risk
nothing they put nothing on the line
they have no skin in the game because
nobody's holding them accountable
now in this next piece of footage we
have a girl being accosted as
she tries to escape to safety trying to
get through the crowd
she's trembling and crying while her
leftist harassers pursuer
watch this and let me know if you can
tell
who the bad guys are here is the bad guy
good guy divide hard to discern in this
situation is there any gray area here
you tell me
hey
[Music]
oh
no you know it's pretty clear when
you're screaming at a sobbing woman as
she tries to get away from you
you're the bad guy that's a pretty safe
rule of thumb
something you can take with you in
everyday life if you ever find yourself
screaming and cussing at a trembling
woman as she clings to a man and tries
to get away from you
there is a very very very good chance
that you are a horrible scumbag
also another tip you might consider the
possibility that you're a scumbag if you
ever find yourself
pushing an old man off his bike and
pouring water on him as
happened here
or you know if you're harassing an
elderly couple because you don't like
their politics
is
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
this again is one-sided okay the
dividing line between right and wrong
and our current culture war is perhaps
clearer now than it's ever been
only one side loots and riots only one
side harasses the elderly only one side
rips down statues
almost all the political violence is on
one side and that also happens to be the
side that believes in killing babies and
injecting hormones into children
this is not a dispute between simply
competing political viewpoints
this is not a mere battle of ideas this
is good versus evil
nothing less than that and let's not
ever forget that point
and this brings us to something else
another important point many
conservatives have
pointed out that democrats say they want
unity even while doing everything we
just saw in those clips
it's clear they don't really want unity
and it's important to make that
observation yes
but to be fair and also to be clear i
don't want unity either
i don't want to unite with people who
who harass and assault the elderly i
don't want to
unite with blm or anyone who supports it
i don't want unity with antifa even if
it was possible which it isn't
i don't desire unity with infanticidal
maniacs
or child abusing scumbags they don't
want unity with me
and that's fine because i don't want it
with them let's not act like our
feelings are heard
because they don't want to be our
friends and that's how it comes across
sometimes
when we say oh you don't really want
unity why won't you be our friends i
don't want to be their friends
speaking for myself that's that's just
not the dynamic here
they're screaming fu at me and all of us
and my response is
right back at you so where does that
leave us
if the divisions are are so deep that
the people on either side of it don't
even want to bridge the gap
even in theory how can we go on how can
we have a functioning society a real
country how can we be
a people rather than just people
the answer is obvious but nobody wants
to admit it or say it out loud and it's
this
we can't we can't be a real country
we can't be a people we can't function
together as a whole
not like this in order for that to
happen
one side or the other would have to
surrender would have to give up what
defines it
would have to stop being what the other
side despises
short of that the differences are as
divorce attorneys say irreconcilable
is that then where we're headed to a to
a national divorce of sorts
no i don't know part of me thinks that's
inevitable
the other part of me thinks we don't
have it in us that we'll be fine to just
coast along like this as a shell of a
country hating each other but living
together for convenience like bill and
hillary
perhaps the the internet and streaming
and video games all enable us to
retreat into virtual worlds and false
realities so that the untenable nature
of our actual reality
continues to seem somewhat tenable maybe
that's where this goes
namely nowhere in circles
i'm not sure what the distant distant
future holds but
as for the near future what i will say
is this
um these blm and antifa militants
you know what they really want to do is
they want to punish conservatives for
voting for trump the goal is to make
sure that
we never have the audacity to vote for a
big scary bully like trump ever again
but the the dirty little secret is that
trump
is not a big scary bully he never was
and so i hope that in 2024 we actually
go and find that guy
go find the big scary bully go find the
guy who
is what the left thinks trump is and
elect him the real deal
i already know what his campaign slogan
should be let's give them something to
cry about
i'd vote for that guy might seem a tad
aggressive but the point is
i don't intend to give one inch to these
people i don't intend to concede one
point
there will not be unity i know that and
so there's nothing to be gained from
making concessions
all we can do now is charge ahead and
let the chips fall
where they may let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
okay so starting here uh dr fauci was on
cnn yesterday and and he wanted to make
sure to
throw some cold water on any embers of
hope
that anyone might have you can't have
any hope no hope is allowed
so here's how that went now you've
already encouraged americans to consider
canceling
any thanksgiving plans that involve
visiting with somebody else or having
visitors come
i know a lot of americans are looking
ahead hoping to make plans for other
holidays such as christmas but
when do you think americans will next be
able to to safely gather together
uh for family events like this are you
suggesting it probably won't be able to
happen until
i don't know labor day 2021 thanksgiving
2021.
now if i could just jump in here for a
second jake if i could briefly
and i know you weren't asking me the
question but i'm going to answer it
anyway
let me say that americans can gather
with their families right now
uh there's no need to wait until labor
day
or you know christmas 2021 i've been
gathering with my family
ever since this all began we had a big
family reunion in in june
i hate to admit it um i don't know i
don't know if the fed's gonna be busting
them out down my door now but that's
that's what we did
we've gotten together plenty since then
we've had some kids birthdays and
other events everybody was fine nobody
got sick
nobody died uh nobody even had a case of
the sniffles afterwards
so my point is you can get together now
if you want to take charge of your own
life make your own decisions
uh be an adult be an american you could
do that
so that's my response to that but here's
fauci's response
you know it depends on a number of
factors jake for example
we have vaccines now the first one that
came out was highly effective
i anticipate that the second one likely
will be comparable
you never can tell until you see the
data but would be comparable
that's great but we have to get people
to take the vaccine
so if we get the overwhelming majority
of people taking the vaccine and you
have on the one hand an effective
vaccine
on the other hand a high degree of
uptake of the vaccine
we could start getting things back to
relative
normal as we get into the second and
third quarter of the year
where people can start thinking about
doing things that were too dangerous
just months ago
but we've got to put all those things
together jake we can't just wish it
happening we've got to get the vaccine
it's got to be deployed and we can't
abandon
fundamental public health measures you
can approach a degree of normality
while still doing some fundamental
public health things
that synergize with the vaccine to get
us back to normal
so not until the second or third quarter
of 2021 though
christmas is probably not going to be
possible yeah i'm okay so we have two
things there first of all we have a
christmas is not going to be possible
from jake tapper
and and the thing is he he said that
yesterday and that this clip went went
viral
on twitter uh with people accusing jake
tapper of saying that essentially we
have to cancel
christmas or at least with our families
you can't get together with chris for
christmas with your families
and the spin from uh people trying to
defend jake tapper is that no no he
didn't he didn't say that he was he
what he was trying to say is that um
it's not gonna be possible to have a
vaccine by christmas well no you heard
it right there that's not what he was
saying
he said christmas is not going to be
possible can't we can't do christmas
that's what he said it was right there
in the clip you heard it for yourself
uh but again jake tapper doesn't get to
cancel christmas
dr fought she doesn't get to cancel it
the governor of your state wherever you
live
cannot cancel it they can try and they
are trying
but they can't actually do it
what needs to happen here is we we call
their bluff
and i think that's what people should
have been doing all along but especially
when it comes to these limits on the
numbers of people you can have in your
own home
for thanksgiving or christmas or just in
general call their bluff
go ahead if you live up in new york you
know you have as many people as you want
over for thanksgiving
if if andrew cuomo really wants to send
police busting down your door to
cart your in-laws away which part of
that frankly seems a little bit
appealing but
if he really wants to do that you know
maybe it's kind of a win-win uh
you know on one side your in-laws get
arrested on the other side of it as well
uh
you know i maybe that will be the thing
that finally wakes up the american
population i don't know
so we have that we also have fauci
saying that
even with the vaccine we still are going
to have to
uh have masks and social distancing and
all these all these
so-called protective measures so let's
follow the trajectory here
with the masks first they said if
if we try to remember in our heads um
originally they said don't wear a mask
no remember they didn't just say don't
wear a mask
they said essentially if you wear a mask
you're a [ __ ] remember those tweets
from the surgeon general
screaming at people seriously stop
wearing masks you morons
you didn't say morons but that was the
tone of it so originally was don't wear
a mask
and then it was well probably you should
wear a mask when you're out in public
um you know uh or you know if you're if
you're if you're out of the store or
something there's strangers around
probably you should wear a mask
and then it was probably you should wear
a mask outside too
and then it was we should just wear
masks all the time
and now they're saying uh yeah you
should wear masks even with your when
you're with your own family for
thanksgiving
and oh yeah we should probably actually
we're gonna wear masks even after the
vaccine
and we're just gonna wear masks forever
pretty soon it would be after you die
you wear a mask in the grave
because you can never be too careful
uh number two staying on this on this
theme here washington state
is going into full lockdown again in
fact a number of states are
this this was the most recent one
announced this in michigan
so here's the governor of washington
introducing the rehashed measures that
didn't work the first time so let's try
them again
so the restrictions we're announcing
today which will be in effect through
december 14th
are not as comprehensive or some degree
tough as our stay home order in march
but every part of our state will see
robots in some sense
most will take effect at the at uh
midnight monday
this is not forever this is only for now
thanks to the brilliance of our medical
community a vaccine is on the way
we need to hold this pandemic down until
the cavalry arrives
this is a temporary situation in our
state where we seek a permanent healthy
condition and our goal is to keep the
most people alive as possible until the
vaccine and other therapeutic measures
arrives
and that's a task i believe washington
is up to so here are some parts of our
plan
indoor social gatherings with people
from outside your home
are prohibited unless they quarantine
for 14 days prior to the social
gathering
or quarantined for the seven days prior
to the gathering
and receive a negative coven 19 test
result
no more than 48 hours prior to the
gathering and they've got a they
released a whole list of of what the
restrictions are
and um i'm looking at it right here
uh just it's a it's a lengthy list
indoor social gatherings with people
from outside your household are
prohibited
unless they quarantine for 14 days
um so they're they're saying it doesn't
there's not even a limit it's just you
can't you can't do it
period unless they quarantine for for 14
days
beforehand outdoor social gatherings
shall be limited to five people from
outside your household
restaurants and bars are closed for
indoor dining service
because you know these these governors
they didn't succeed in completely
killing their economies and
and completely destroying i mean they
decimated the restaurant
industry but they didn't completely
destroy it now they're going back around
for the kill shot
that's what's happening here um gyms and
fitness facilities are closed
um movie theaters are closed
this is the kind of thing this this is
just just completely egregious
and and flagrant why close movie
theaters
there's just no reason to close them you
you could
very easily socially distance in in a
movie there a movie theater would be one
of the easiest things to keep
open because you can easily control the
number of people who come in
you spread them out no problem
you'll be very easy to do they close
bowling alleys bowling alleys are closed
again
no reason for that it'd be extremely
just spread out i mean
when's the last time you've been in a
bowling alley that was completely packed
anyway
maybe have people wear their own shoes
in case you're wondering about covet on
the shoes i don't know
there's there's just so many really
basic things we could do
without shutting down these industries
but these governors almost all of them
democrats are saying yeah forget that
we'll just we'll just destroy the
industry why not
uh number three a report here from the
blaze says actress melissa mccarthy
known for her roles in comedic films
caved to the outrage mob last week after
she was attacked online for donating
money to an organization dedicated to
ending human sex trafficking
so she's apologizing for giving money to
a charity
against human sacrificing all right um
so the she's uh part of a promotion for
the new movie super intelligence
mccarthy teamed up with hbo max for 20
days of kindness
which is a campaign donating 20 donating
20 thousand dollars to 20 different
charities
over the course of 20 days so far so
good
included on the list was exodus cry
which is a non-profit
organization dedicated to eradicating
sex trafficking
um but the daily beast got wind of this
and they did a hit piece on exodus cry
and here's what they said it's from the
daily beast
the daily beasts uh tarpley hit
exclusively reported on thursday that
exodus cry frames itself as an anti-sex
trafficking group but in reality works
to abolish
sex work entirely oh the horror
its founder benjamin noah has called
abortion a holocaust
and homosexuality an unspeakable offense
to god
the group has spent years lobbying to
criminalize the purchase of sex and
uh recently launched campaign to shutter
pornhub that sounds like a great
this is the first time i've heard of
access crime but i'll tell you right now
i'm gonna be donating to them
i'm gonna make a handsome donation
exodus cry sound great to me
uh so that's the great offense though
they they not only try to rescue women
from sex trafficking
but they also oppose the industries that
depend on sex trafficking
and that drives sex trafficking so they
want to bail the water
out of the boat and plug the leak well
that's that's horrible that's bigoted
it's better to keep baling the titanic
out with little mop buckets and
thimbles while leaving the iceberg size
gash in the hall because that's
that's on the left when they talk about
battling sex trafficking
that's what they want to do because as
far as the industries that keep this
going
that depend on it fund it push it um
fuel it
they don't do anything with those
industries
and so melissa mccarthy anyway brave
woman that she is um
she got a little bit of a push back and
uh and decided to
take the money back and she issued this
groveling apology
hi there um it has come to our attention
that our 20 days of kindness
which is something a kindness hub that
we started to kind of shed
light on 20 great charities had one um
in there that there's no other way to
say it we blew it we made a mistake and
we backed a charity
that upon proper vetting stands for
everything that we do not
um so i want to thank everyone um on
social media who said what are you doing
are you sure you want to back this
because the answer is no we do not
we have pulled it we are so incredibly
grateful
for you ringing the bell and helping us
be better
we're sorry for our mistake oh boy are
we sorry for it can't believe that we
missed it
um and that's it and i just uh
i want to say hope it doesn't ding the
other charities because they're really
doing some amazing things and 20 days of
kindness
uh is really meant to shine the light on
all of those wonderful charities so
let the kindness continue and uh thank
you
thanks for the help we really needed it
just a picture of courage there
that melissa mccarthy isn't she i mean
just think about this you she could have
easily ignored this
she could have taken that route just
ignore it it'll go away people aren't
people aren't that focused on it or she
could have done the right thing and come
out and said
hey listen this is a good organization
they're fighting sex trafficking
i don't agree with all their views but
but they're
they're doing an important service and
um and you know if they're again if
they're against
pornhub while at the same time saving
women from sex trafficking
that's a trait i'm willing to make she
could have done that
and she she risks nothing but nothing
speaking of putting nothing on the line
having no stakes what what
you know if she were to stand up against
the outrage mob
what happens to her what's the worst
case scenario
that her super intelligence movie flops
it was gonna flop anyway
all of her movies flop um but she's
still a multi-millionaire she'll still
get work
so that's that's why it can be so
demoralizing when you see these
people on the on the public stage who
are massively wealthy
and they've got so many fans and
everything and they cave so quickly to
the outrage mob
because for them it should be the
easiest to stand against it think about
drew brees another another perfect
example
you know deciding he he for a moment he
stood up for
the ant literally for the anthem and for
police got a little bit of pushback and
said oh never mind i'm sorry i'm sorry
for supporting the flag
and supporting police uh you're right i
you know what i am going to take the
side of of of you know convicted
criminals and
and uh instead instead of the police
but what was the worst case scenario for
him if he stood up against the outrage
mob
what happens to him even if he gets cut
from the team which was never going to
happen because he's drew brees
for god's sake but even if he did he's
still he's still rich and wealthy still
still set for life he could do whatever
he wants
but if these people who have everything
won't stand up when they when they
really risk nothing if they won't stand
up against it
what about people who don't have that
kind of security that's why it's so
demoralizing um okay let's go to number
four this is
from the daily wire says not content to
ban smoking in public san francisco is
now considering a ban
on smoking in one's own home should they
live in an apartment
uh reason reported that the city's board
of supervisors are considering the bill
and voted last thursday to advance it
the bill would ban smoking inside
private dwellings located in apartments
with three or more units according to
the outlet
the bill wouldn't apply to just tobacco
products with known second-hand concerns
it would also ban marijuana and even
vaping in the private dwellings
the san francisco examiner reported
saying the bill sponsored
bill sponsor supervisor norman yay said
in a tweet that the goal of the bill was
to help residents avoid being exposed to
secondhand smoke in their own homes
he says smoke easily moves between units
and buildings
now that more of us work from home it's
more important than ever because there
is no way to contain it
by the way there's no evidence
whatsoever
that if your neighbor smokes it's
somehow going to give you cancer
no evidence of that there just isn't um
[Music]
but i think it's not a coincidence here
i don't see this as a coincidence that
on one hand you've got these coveted
restrictions
and state governments assuming they have
the right and the power to tell you how
many people
you can have in your own home and now
you get a smoking ban in
private residences you know it's we're
setting a precedent with the coveted
restrictions
and it's not going to be contained just
to that i think we've already seen that
and the precedent is the government can
tell you what you can do in your own
home
and this is there there are going to be
consequences to that
we have seen this over and over again
with with the government i mean
throughout human history
when you give the government when you
submit to that to the government and
give it a certain power
it's not just going to give it back and
and always it always it always well
we need the power just an emergency
situation here we just need it for now
give us this power and we but we'll give
it up once once the emergency
passes and time and time again of course
the public says well okay
if you say so you never lied to us
before except every other time
so that's the way this is going to go
number five finally um
if if joe biden is going to be president
then i think we found
the anthem for the next four years this
i think um
i think we could say at least this is
the best
pro-biden song ever written though of
course the bar is so low that it's
you know somewhere now down near the
core of the earth at this point but
anyway uh here's the song listen
i can't believe it
all my dreams came true
[Music]
america voted
and the country turned blue
[Music]
we wanted joe biden
for the next four years
we wanted kamala
[Music]
trump can't defeat
[Music]
yeah the second hand embarrassment is so
intense
watching that that you feel like you're
suffering actual physical trauma
while you watch it and i i just i
i what i'm i'm wondering is whose idea
was that i assume it was the guy's idea
because he's the lead singer
so the guy went up to his girlfriend or
his wife or whoever
maybe his uber passenger i don't know
and said hey babe
i wrote this uh this sexy joe biden song
what do you say we hop in the front seat
and sing it together
and the crazy thing is that she said yes
to that
maybe she didn't ask to hear it ahead of
time that's what i'm thinking so she's
sitting there
listening and experiencing the same
horror we are
but she's on camera she can't show it
the show must go on
suddenly this has become a story of
great courage and selflessness
on the part of the woman and that's
that's how i choose to see it
in an inspiring way all right um
speaking of inspiring we're gonna get to
our daily cancellation in just a second
but before
we do you know we're talking about the
these shutdowns which are ramping up
again in many states
uh schools are being shut down again a
lot of schools have been shut down the
whole time we're doing remote learning
and everything
and the point is that many parents
across the country millions of new
parents are considering
homeschooling and they're realizing that
you know homeschooling is a great option
especially now but even going forward
to take charge of your child's education
um to put yourself in charge of your
child's education
that's a great idea so if you're a
parent who homeschools or
or or wants to home school but you're
feeling overwhelmed with all the work
and responsibilities
that are on your shoulders right now you
know we're a homeschool family and uh we
mean you know we can tell you that's
that's how it is of course my wife does
most of the homeschooling and uh so she
especially could tell you
what what a struggle it can be and how
overwhelming it can feel
when you are in charge of your child's
education and for parents with kids in
school you know if you've if you've
avoided the need to pull your student
out of the public school system because
it just seems too daunting to homeschool
them this
this year yourself well homeschool
magnet
is for parents just like you whatever
category you're in it's a parent it's
for a parent just like you homeschool
magnet supports homeschooling families
by providing students with instruction
from world-class credential teachers in
a remote classroom
with their peers parents can choose the
best teachers for each student based on
the values and teaching approach to
ensure
that every child is receiving exactly
the education they desire
and i think that's so important that
they're letting you choose teachers
based not just on on the subject and the
education style but also on the values
because that's part of education you
know let's let's face it part of
education
is instilling values into a child
uh and rather than pretending that
education can be
objective or that you can separate
values from education rather than
pretending because that's just not the
case
we need to embrace that homeschooling is
about embracing that
and that's what homeschool magnet is all
about each student will receive
instruction in the four
core subject areas of math english
language arts
english language arts science and social
studies other online schools exist of
course but homeschool magnet is unique
even though home school magnet includes
a robust online learning environment
each student works from real physical
learning materials
guided by video instruction from their
teacher so there is that physical
element to it which is really important
homeschool magnet is only a fraction of
the cost of private schools and the
30-day money-back guarantee upon
enrollment means this choice is
risk-free you might as well give it a
shot
and i can tell you again as a homeschool
family i couldn't recommend it enough
to learn more about homeschool magnets
student experience go to
homeschoolmagnet.com and join the
growing weightlift
waitlist for interested teachers who
want more freedom in their teaching
career homeschool magnet
may also be perfect for you so we're
recruiting new teachers now go to
homeschoolmagnet.com
to learn more and apply now okay let's
get to our daily cancellation
today we reflect on the state of the
culture from the perspective of a
christian
who confronts it we find that basic
truths have been
turned into heresies objective reality
and
moral decency are anathema the family is
under assault
children are under assault masculinity
and femininity are under assault
and from the standpoint of religion
church attendance is wimbling america is
becoming more atheist more secular by
the day
but on top of all of this the
unprecedented assault on religious
liberty
currently underway church is being shut
down congregations
banned from singing or worshiping in
large groups and these restrictions look
to be getting
tighter again across the country i mean
this year we have actually seen
pastors arrested and hauled off to jail
for holding church services that is
happening in this country
congregants fined for attending those
services and there is no sign of any of
this
getting any better any time soon but
have no fear
the united states bishops are here
this week begins their general assembly
they're of course all virtual
general assembly and there's quite a lot
for these bishops to discuss to put it
mildly
uh for catholics after all these are
supposed to be our our field
generals our leaders on the cultural
battlefield one would hope that they
you know are going into this meeting
with fire in their bellies adrenaline in
their veins ready to conquer the
darkness like modern-day conquistadors
like cortez charging into an aztec city
burning its temple of human sacrifice to
the ground
that's what you would hope if you've
been living in a cave
since well around the time of cortez it
may be what you would hope and expect
and if so by the way you picked the
wrong century to emerge from hiding
because this is not a time for warrior
bishops
at least not in the west and that's why
heading into the general assembly
rather than standing up against
persecution or shining light in the
darkness or fighting evil
the bishops are talking about baby yoda
yes baby yoda here's here's the tweet
that went out from the united states
conference of catholic bishops twitter
account
it says we meet tomorrow for our first
ever all virtual
general assembly how many baby yoda
gifts do you think we'll post during the
conference
and then there's a poll a little fun
poll you could participate in and you
could vote
more than five or less than five
now this provoked some understandable
confusion
and people were asking why the bishops
are tweeting about baby yoda
and they explained later in the thread
they said we started posting them at our
meeting last year
they had just started to be widely
shared online
you know the joke has gone poorly when
it has to be explained
and of course the bishops sound like
massive nerds explaining it
yes we posted the graphics interchange
format of a popular star wars character
it was quite humorous spectacle it even
caused some of us to as they say
lol now i know it may seem like i'm
unfairly giving the bishops a hard time
here all they did was tweet about baby
yoda
what's the big deal but the problem is
that this is very much a part of a
larger trend a trend
prevalent in the western church
generally not just catholic but across
the board
church leaders make themselves
irrelevant by focusing on frivolous
nonsense
while ignoring the great battle that
wages around them
now you could tolerate somebody cracking
jokes on the battlefield
if they were kicking ass and taking
names as they did it and if the jokes
were good
but neither of those applied to the
bishops or to most church leaders
and that's the problem you could maybe
tolerate
the lack of seriousness the flippancy
the frivolity
if it was effective if it was appealing
if it has
if it had the supposed desired effect of
appealing to the
wayward youth etc but it's not and it
doesn't
i am reminded here and i could give so
many similar examples but
i'm reminded of a sermon i once heard um
not long ago
at a church based around the movie toy
story
and the point of the sermon the message
from what i remember was that
friendship is important you know because
woody and buzz
got off to a rocky start but they
discovered the power of friendship
and it took them to infinity and beyond
i can't remember if that line was
actually in the sermon but it could have
been that was that was the theme
i i'm also made to remember uh here a
christian
or rather a christmas sermon that i
heard a couple years ago
based around the grinch who stole
christmas
now you might think that if you're
looking for a relevant christmas story
to base your homily around
you might choose you know the christmas
story the nativity
but no the grinch who stole christmas
because the priest wanted to be relevant
and hip and because he had the cultural
knowledge of my 95 year old grandmother
so he thought the grinch was the best
way that he could accomplish that
this has long been the story in the
western church irrelevance
lack of seriousness outdated pop culture
references
bad jokes all in the name of appealing
to the youth
but the youth are not impressed because
they hunger for something deep
and real and true and relevant
not baby yoda gifts so
the bishops are canceled baby yoda
is also canceled guilt by association
that's how it goes with the daily
cancellation
i'm sorry yoda that's gonna do it for us
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
leftist militants attack trump
supporters in dc liberal elites violate
all their own lockdown rules and target
tries to trans the kids check it out on
the michael knowles show
you